we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i asked
yesterday should i be reporting every
day on gun deaths we did a sample report
at the top of todays show and i received
a bunch of emails and voicemails and
comments about this here's one voicemail
that came in about this idea david in
your last show you were suggesting that
you should cover gun deaths on a regular
basis or in the beginning of the show as
you said right i would greatly
appreciate that we see on a regular
basis conservatives using disingenuous
arguments to basically you will the
right-wing propaganda push it further
they play into it without realizing the
actual information and i do feel that
you have such a strong point on this
that you might be able to convince a
couple people and if we don't keep
banging the drum until we get results we
might never get results I fear that
Vegas will actually not lead to gun
control I fear it will take something
much much much larger and the culprit of
that is not banging the drum hard enough
thank you David
yeah well listen I I don't think that if
Vegas is not going to trigger real
significant pushes towards gun safety
regulation I don't think me reading the
previous day's gun deaths is going to
but that being said if you like the idea
of just to catch up at the top or end of
each show with the number of people
killed by guns the previous day it's
definitely something that I would
consider doing on the bonus show today
that cop who forcibly arrested a nurse
in Utah for refusing to draw blood has
been fired child and teen obesity rates
have soared tenfold worldwide in 40
years we'll dig into those numbers and
confusion between Donald Trump in the
NFL on a policy around standing or not
standing during the national anthem all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show how do you access the bonus
show it's very easy you just get a
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership you make a patreon pledge of
Phi
dollars at patreon.com slash david
pakman show both will get you instant
access to the bonus show I will speak to
you then